In 1998, a paper in a major medical journal proposed a link between autism...
...and the vaccination for measles, mumps and rubella.
The popular press and some celebrities...
...fueled anxiety about vaccinations based on this report.
In fact, over a dozen studies have failed to find any connection between autism and vaccines...
...and that original paper was retracted amid allegations of fraud and conflicts of interest.
Yet the actions of celebrities and the media can have a lasting effect.
More than half of Americans still suspect there's a link between vaccines and autism.
The consequences can be serious.
In Ireland, vaccinations dropped about 30%,...
...resulting in 1500 new cases of measles and mumps, including three deaths.
And in the US, states with lower vaccination rates...
...are currently experiencing outbreaks of measles and epidemic levels of whooping cough.
So don't be immune to good advice;...
...better a sore bottom, than a deadly bottom line.